[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
we've been playing fortnite for a very
long time now
1 326 days if you're watching this video
the day i make it
over the years we've seen hundreds of
easter eggs and secrets
well today i decided to find one easter
egg from
every single season of fortnite that's
16 in total
my job was simple to find the least
known secrets
and your job is to see how many you knew
do me a favor and throw a thumbs up if
you like this content
and my code is adamaru if you fancy
supporting my content you ready to do
this
let's go all the way back to season zero
of fortnite battle royale
september 2017 it all began
a new free-to-play game dropped and who
would have thought it'd take over all
our lives
but let's not get bogged down in
nostalgia just yet
our first easter egg is something which
has never
ever been explained back on the original
island sat
a shipping freight landfill we all
called containers
it was the place to drop if you wanted
crazy amounts of metal
what was found after destroying all
those crates was a real secret
look at this an indestructible case
what was more intriguing was inside the
brown luggage
a miniature machine and a conveyor belt
of
cabbages it was confusing back then it's
still confusing today
it stayed in the game for over a year
and we still don't have any answers
the cabbages became real mechanics in
chapter 2 years later
but still no one knows the origins of
the original fortnite easter egg
okay season one proper this time and an
easter egg which you see
every time you play fortnite have you
ever ventured
into a kitchen in game the tiled floor
the high quality decor
well take a look at the milk carton if
you're an old man like me you'll likely
recognize this
it's the same design as in a famous
music video named coffee
and tv by british band blur it's
actually a really good video about a
lost person
the fortnite designer who created this
asset must have been a fan
back in the 1990s
when season 2 came around the streaming
of fortnite blew up
and made celebrities overnight back then
we didn't have many items to spend money
on in the shop
and probably the most famous fortnite
player ever ninja
wanted that to change he said in a tweet
he was pretty upset that there have been
no
new skins and i'm literally throwing
money at the game
and here's the best part dude i would
buy a toilet plunger
as an axe so what did epic do they
created the first reference to a
streamer
the plunger it's a it's a
plunger fast forward a few years and
ninja became one of the first people to
have his own skin
in game but ogs like us will never
forget
the real easter egg here
season three of fortnite and probably my
favorite easter egg in this entire
series
remember the house all alone in between
greasy grove and tilted towers
for a few weeks there was a very secret
easter egg here at the top of the stairs
was a set of drawers
and on top of that was a note which read
andrea will you go to prom with me
eric i couldn't find if andrea said yes
or not
but is there a cooler way to ask your
girl to prom than in fortnite
okay there probably is now but in 2018
this was the height
of awesomeness
season 4 arrived and the entire world
began playing fortnite
the superhero theme season brought in
tons of new players
in terms of easter eggs the season was
packed but not that many were secret
so take this down at flush factory it
was possible to walk into the toilet
room
and instantly the porta-potties would
change color
blue and pink for male and female this
was a live change totally dynamic
it was removed later that season and now
the toilets are permanently pink or blue
regardless of proximity it was pointless
but i liked it
[Music]
next to season five when worlds collide
the easter egg of choice
this season is thanks to a shouty
australian nice guy muzelk
who tried to save a trapped opponent on
the sandy side of the island
a chap named chappadoodle was stranded
below the build limit of the game
he was left stuck waiting for the storm
to put him out of his misery
luckily muzelk was on hand and devised a
plan to rescue him
by bringing down an atk and using the
roof as a jump pad
to get back to build height and here's
what happened
i'm coming for you boy i'm coming for
you hold on music's here
oh no all right b the atk method of
jumping back up
did work though after seeing this epic
games added a gravestone here to mark
the passing of chapadoodle
and also included some tyres to help out
if anyone fell down here in future
season six the season in which kevin was
a floating island
ah good memories season six had a very
interesting easter egg which arguably
was one of the first crossovers really
a new movie in the wreck-it ralph
universe dropped and in one of the
scenes
ralph travels to multiple video games
via the internet
and fortnite was one of those places if
you were lucky enough to be in the right
place at the right time
aka risky reels every 19 minutes or so
you'd see the big man pass through and
that's it
a simple walkthrough to mark the movie's
release we all received the hot marat
emote too
nice touch quality easter egg ggs all
round
season seven was a bit of a duff season
in terms of easter eggs but hey the
marshmallow concert was damn good
so here's one of the emotes instead
showstopper this
is taken from a chris farley sketch in
which he's trying to be
a male stripper i'm sure you'll agree he
has the perfect body
when season eight arrived so did the
most memeed easter egg on the internet
hidden in a paper airplane glider was a
schoolboy scribble which read
my name jeff and yeah you know where
this one is from
my name 22 jump street is the best worst
film you will ever watch
season nine this was the start of the
crossover way of thinking in fortnite
at the start of the season we found a
house which looked a lot like the one
found in the john wick movies
a few seasons earlier we even had a fake
john wick character
named the reaper so things lined up well
the thing which proved this to all of us
that this was a john wick reference was
down in the basement
just like the movie under the concrete
floor was jon's secret loot stash
should he ever come out of retirement
the thing which took this subtle easter
egg into a new direction for fortnite
was revealed about six weeks later and
the addition
of the very real john wick this was an
awkward meet-up between the two
season 10 aka season x the season
in which the world was destabilizing
yeah i'm gonna play i'm gonna play it
and the world is destabilizing
fast but don't worry this was the final
season for the og island
as it was eaten by a black hole and
fortnight didn't exist for a few days
luckily there was an easter egg during
these dark days
by using a 30 year old secret code known
as the konami code
we could play a hidden arcade game
straight out of the 1980s
a slice of pizza shooting burgers out of
space
hey didn't do much but it helped pass
the bottom of staring into the void for
hours
chapter 2 arrived and a whole new island
to look around
filled with secrets and easter eggs i'm
gonna call this season 11 to keep things
flowing
up at steamy stacks is what we're
looking at a nuclear power plant
created from the power of kevin the cube
this location is based on the power
plant found in the simpsons
which spews out waste into the local
water supply
and to 100 confirm this easter egg we
can find
homer's workstation in fortnite covered
in pink frosted donuts
season 12 arrived and really took the
game to a new level with weekly updates
and map changes and a core plot around
midas and his goons
a truly great season in the battle pass
was none other than deadpool
the merc with a mouth he was hiding in a
secluded toilet
via an in-game vent fortnight is strange
but just go with it
in here deadpool had a pc and our
challenges would appear here each week
the easter egg we're looking for was
hidden here all along by
minimizing the info on screen we could
click on the icons on the desktop
and one of those deadpool's face was
actually a mini game
a skiing deadpool going down a mountain
avoiding
evil pigleys it was strangely addictive
too
season 13 now down under steamy stacks
sits a false wall with a room behind it
in here you'll find part of the
algorithm
a piece of law from the movie tenet when
all these parts are aligned the user can
control
time in the movie they use it to reverse
the flow of time
the thing about this easter egg is it's
still in game right now
go check for yourself is this a
forgotten easter egg or is this linked
to the storyline
i regularly go back and check on it just
in case it has the power to take us back
to chapter one
season 14 let's crack on we're almost
through this just like last season an
easter egg popped up without
anyone noticing but this time it was
linked to a shop item
the ghostbusters arrived in fortnite the
easter egg for these guys is still in
the game right now
down at camp cod in the dirty barn sits
a vehicle with a cover over it
looking closely we can see that this is
the ecto-1
and to be doubly sure give it a whack
the iconic ghostbusters siren will ring
out
beautiful subtle lovely little easter
egg
[Music]
on to season 15. the zero point popped
up again i'm sorry mando from the star
wars universe
the easter egg you may have missed is
another for a youtuber this time
cipher pk one of his longest running
series is designed to help plebs like me
improve at fortnight and to do this he
regularly lands at the weather station
above catty corner he spoke about his
playbook many times
and fortnite were listening they added
an indestructible book
up in the mountains in homage to cipher
how cool is that
how big do you have to be to get a
fortnight easter egg can i have graham
the gnome dabbing on the haters please
epic
worth a shot i guess
and we made it all the way up to season
16 and the primal era
this time around we have lara croft here
an archaeologist with a death wish
and literally the week i'm saying this
became the time we could unlock her
final skin variation
a golden lara we do this by visiting
aurelia a character inspired by the myth
of midas
a king with the power to turn anything
into gold simply by touch
what if i told you this isn't the first
time lara has been turned into gold
back in the ps1 days lara found a tomb
and a broken statue of king midas
the thing was if she stood on the hand
this happened
lara became a golden statue and that's
why we can unlock this skin in fortnite
it's a homage it's an easter egg
to lara's anniversary i think she's 25
now she's getting on a bit so there we
have it
16 seasons and 16 secret easter eggs
in fact 17 because we included season
zero too
how many did you know come on you can be
honest how did i do i'll be looking out
for your scores in the comments below
i'm adam you're awesome and so are these
legends on screen right now who used my
code
adamaru last week thank you very much i
really appreciate it
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]